le savez maintenant que lorsque les
stars de le faire bouger les choses en
politique
elle appelle directement il va nouvelle
manne après il y en a qui avait
interpellé le président sur le sujet de
l'éducation c'est selena gomez
cette fois qui a envoyé un message au
chef de l'état regardez elle lui dit
prise jack et demi je vais lire en
français
ouais c'est loupé envoyé un message au
président français emmanuel macron ainsi
qu aux autres leaders du g 7 castaldi
n'a rien su pour des doses pour aider
les gens partout dans le monde à se
battre contre la pandémie de covile 19
c'est une belle initiative
selena et le président lui a répondu oui
emmanuelle wacongne répondu voilà ce
qu'il a écrit cherche jelen à gomez
merci d'avoir transmis ce message
crucial à tous les dirigeants
la france a déjà commencé à envoyer ses
premières doses de vaccin en afrique via
kovacs et ce n'est que le début
merci d'avoir fait passer le mot restons
aux côtés de ceux qui en auront au moins
maintenant c'est bien elle est
l'ambassadrice d'un concert caritatif et
la france a envoyé 100 mille doses en
afrique
baran faut 500 milles en juin il ya
encore du boulot et c'est bien du budget
c'est bien de bouger oui non il est
malin il sait que c'est bon pour son
image ça touche des jeunes en france et
à l'international selena gomez elle est
dix fois plus suivis qu'emmanuel mâcon
60 millions de followers 6 millions
seulement pour emmanuel macron jeu c'est
bien celle-là je la connais un petit peu
comment vous la connaissez rien à dire
de plus car on peut s'aider à gomez
c'est bien beau mais c'est vaste gamme
selena oui oui c'est votre coeur c'est
pas du tout mon délire c'est un agressé
pas du tout mes délires admet qu'elle
m'a jamais demandé si vous avez évacuer
un peu rapidement le sujet mais vous
dites que vous avez un
à tout lire c'est à dire je connais je
connaissais la gomez s'est déjà
rencontré mais où vous êtes déjà
rencontré way où ça sent seule facture
interposés ou par lord emmanuel macron
je sais pas si vous voulez vu cette
vidéo qui a fait le buzz aujourd'hui ça
s'est passé lors d'un déplacement à
melun à l'occasion de la rentrée des
classes lui une maman a jeté son bébé
dans les bras du président pour avoir
une photo avec lui c'était exceptionnel
et et le président fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est exceptionnel ça très drôle ça
franchement le visage du bébé qui
regardent en disant mais qu'est ce que
je fais mais nan mais c'est toi comment
ça va rester un souvenir c'est sûr la
femme a limité a bien fait c'est drôle
parce que ça va rester un souvenir
incroyable je t'ai mis dans les bras du
président il exhume des jeux